[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHERINE MILLER: Hi, Rami.
I hope you're enjoying
the last day here
of Google Cloud Next 2018.
RAMI SHALOM: I am.
KATHERINE MILLER: I'm
really excited to learn
from you about Stackdriver
Transparent SLI Monitoring.
Can you tell me a little
bit about this demo?
RAMI SHALOM: Absolutely.
So what we're demoing here is
one of the capabilities of one
of the products in
Stackdriver Suite.
And what we're doing
here, actually,
is enabling developers
and operational people
to monitor their service that
they're getting from Google.
So for instance, if your
application is involving
multiple pieces inside
Google Cloud-- say Spanner,
or Bigtable, or BigQuery--
every API call that you
are making to Google
is something that we measure,
and we give you the information
about what we see.
So in that case, if
something goes wrong
and you need something
that will enable
you to know what's
going on, we're
going to give you the
Google side of things.
So if something
on the Google side
is malfunctioning
or is misbehaving,
we'll be transparent
and give you
the information about how
Google is treating you.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
And so I think you might have
answered my next question.
But what is it that makes
this helpful and useful
to developers?
RAMI SHALOM: Oh, that's
actually a great question.
So think about the
fact that if you
have an application that you
own, and your application is
composed of your code as
an application server,
but it relies on
services from Google
and it makes API calls
to certain pieces
of the infrastructure,
you would want
to know, first and foremost,
when something happens.
Say you have a long
latency, or you
have a lot of error messages,
or your customer is complaining
about something, you want to be
able to pinpoint the right area
where the problem is.
And so we give you the
indication how the underlying
services of Google are behaving,
and if this is the case,
get to know where to
focus your attention
first-- get in touch with Google
to fix the problem that we have
on our side, or focus on your
application which is actually
misbehaving, and the APIs are
actually behaving correctly.
KATHERINE MILLER: OK, excellent.
Well, thank you so
much for sharing
a little bit about the demo,
and enjoy the rest of the show.
RAMI SHALOM: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]